madame monsieur bonjour et merci d'être
fidèle à dimanche en politique en
bourgogne aujourd'hui je reçois le
député de la nièvre christian paul
bonjour christian paul bonjour alors on
va donc parler de l'avenir de la gauche
jusqu'à midi mais aujourd'hui quand même
c'est jour de vote
c'est le premier tour de la primaire de
la droite et du centre on connaîtra les
résultats ce soir à priori est ce que
vous vous êtes intéressé à cette
campagne vous avez regardé le débat je
dis cela je vais regarder les trois
débats
peut-être par conscience citoyenne est
aussi voter c'est sûr que non c'est une
primaire qui est si j'ai bien compris
celle des citoyens qui se retrouvent
dans les valeurs de la droite et du sang
donc ce ce moment démocratique n'est pas
le mien nous aurons une primeur de la
gauche
voilà la fin du mois de janvier donc il
faut déjà le dire j'ai regardé j'ai
regardé ce débat je les ai trouvés sur
la forme assez convenue j'espère que
pour les débats de la primaire de gauche
on arrive à trouver peut-être une forme
moins moins figé dans ses danses et un
échange mais là n'est pas l'essentiel la
forme l'emportent pas sur le fond et sur
le fond je dois dire là d une profonde
déception alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi vous qui êtes à gauche vous
vous inquiétez delà du vide parfois deux
ou du manque d'imagination des candidats
de la droite mais je pensais que pendant
cinq ans il avait eu la possibilité de
renouveler d'une certaine façon le
projet politique de la droite et je
trouve ce projet tel qu'il est exposé là
par ses candidats
l'une ou l'un d'entre eux sera le
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
donc sera évidemment en premier plan
j'ai trouvé que en fait il y avait un
formidable retour en arrière cinq cent
mille suppressions de postes
françois fillon 308 pour les autres dans
la fonction publique
on se demande où l'accès des policiers
des gendarmes des des infirmières c'est
le service les services publics celui ci
qui peut être aussi évidemment
profondément dégradé la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune et au total on
vous l'avait été tous dans le même
panier
bien sûr il ya des moments où on
comprend que ces candidats sont pas à
côté de la modernité savent qu'internet
existe depuis 20 ans mais je n'ai pas
trouvé de souffle nouveau je n'ai pas
trouvé d'idées nouvelles et après cinq
ans dans l'opposition je pense qu'il
aurait été nécessaire que la droite
revienne
non pas avec un esprit de revanche mais
plutôt avec la volonté de voilà de m un
projet sur la table que les français est
en vie véritablement et je pense que je
pense que les français c'est ce que
j'entends noms n'ont pas été convaincus
par ces débats est en tout cas moi je
réalisais bien combien nous serons allés
voter en tout cas tout plutôt régressif
ces programmes on va voir combien seront
allés voter ce soir et vous avez un
favori non pas du tout ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas ma primeur en tout cas cette
primaire de la droite et mieux
organisées que ne l'est celle de la
gauche ou à vous croire puisque vous
avez fait une déclaration à la fp
c'était vendredi soir
je vous cite il y a un retard à
l'allumage ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les menaces sur ces primaires
nous les avons voulu nous les avons
obtenus au départ contre l'avis du
président la république de l'état major
du parti socialiste qui n'en voulait pas
donc maintenant il faut en faire un
grand événement démocratique sinon ça ne
sert à rien il faut que ce soit le
moment de l'inventaire du quinquennat et
le moment où des projets des projets
politiques
je l'espère mois pour une alternance à
gauche après ce quinquennat qui a
beaucoup déçu vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure et donc je souhaiterais qu'il y
ait également la ligne r oui mais vous
avez rappelé que je les écris ce que je
souhaite aujourd'hui c'est que l'on
mette vraiment le turbo c'est là qu'il y
ait préparation plus intensive qu'il y
ait de très nombreux bureaux de vote
qu'on n'ait pas à faire 20 km pour aller
voter les 22 et 29 janvier à cette
primaire citoyenne je souhaite que ce
soit d
de gentils se saisissent de cette
primeur donc il faut faire de
l'information autour cette prime alors
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment on parle
beaucoup des primaires de la droite et
je souhaite que dès le lendemain du
second tour de la primaire de droite on
parle vraiment de la primaire de gauche
pas comme une punition mais comme
vraiment un événement démocratique
permettant aux citoyens qui eux se
retrouvent dans les valeurs de la gauche
de choisir leur candidat donc de choisir
véritablement le destin de la gauche
dans cette élection présidentielle qui
va être une élection extrêmement
difficile évidemment
alors justement dans l'actualité aussi
de cette semaine il y la candidature or
primaire de d'emmanuel macron une
candidature irrévocable at il précisé
alors est ce que c'est un épiphénomène
comme certains semblent le penser
emmanuel macron oui alors est ce que
finalement c'est quand même le symbole
vis-à-vis des partis traditionnels dont
il s'affranchit littéralement la ligne
franchie
emmanuel macron il s'affranchit oui les
parties les résultats macro et en
produits chimiques mon pur de la
politique et de l'économie à la
française c'est ce que vous allez il est
alors servi frais oui si on regarde
l'état civil si on regarde les idées je
ne les trouve pas radicalement nouvelle
dans les quelques propositions qu'il a
faites en matière économique sociale eu
de système de retraite temps de travail
je vais pas trouver ça furieusement
révolutionnaire d'autant plus que c'est
généralement déjà dans les propositions
pour certains du d'une partie du
patronat plutôt la partie moderne du
patronat français et c'est des
propositions qu'on trouve d'ailleurs
chez quelques-uns des candidats à la
primaire de la droite tout ça n'est pas
très étonnant donc est ce que est ce que
emmanuel macron il ait pas de grosse
chaleur
ils nous envient pas réellement la
gauche est ce que emmanuel macron
prospèrent sur la dévitalisation des
partis politiques
certainement mais cette dévitalisation
je suis l'un des premiers à le regretter
et est-ce qu'ils prospèrent sur la
déception à l'égard du quinquennat de
françois hollande
bien sûr il est aujourd'hui il est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs un procureur de
ce quinquennat simplement devant la
situation qui est créé par quatre ans et
demi d'exercice du pouvoir par françois
hollande manuel valls ou si il ya deux
attitudes possibles celle d' emmanuel
macron dire sur le sur le flanc droit
en allant chercher donc en même temps
les recettes libérales des réponses à la
situation économique du pays
et puis une autre façon une autre
attitude possible
une autre sortie de cette crise
démocratique qui a été le quinquennat de
françois hollande en allant chercher une
alternance à gauche et je la crois
possible mais c'est quand même une épine
supplémentaire dans le pied de la gauche
non je crois que c'est surtout une
raison plus qui rend extrêmement
difficile une candidature françois
hollande à l'élection présidentielle
vous savez moi je suis de ceux des que
le président s'est auto empêché quelque
sorte mais il a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
difficultés à pouvoir mettre en avant
une candidature
quant au nombre de ceux qui le
soutenaient jusqu'à une date récente
y compris emmanuel macron déserte en
quelque sorte le l'elysée et vous savez
emmanuel macron puisque vous m'avez
interrogé sur la nature même de 2,7
voilà un personnage nouveau dans la vie
politique
moi je les jeux les vues pendant quatre
ans et demi auprès de françois hollande
d'abord à l'elysée principal conseiller
économique et ensuite comme ministre de
l'économie je vous dis franchement je
n'ai pas été impressionné
on a bataillé des jours et des nuits à
l'assemblée nationale sur une loi qui
porte son nom qui n'a pas trouvé de
majorité il a fallu faire appel à
l'article 49-3 là quand on parle de
révolution démocratique
c'est une révolution démocratique à
l'envers et j'ai trouvé en lui un
défenseur inconditionnel à l'époque de
la politique menée françois hollande sur
lequel je suis prêt d'ailleurs à ce
qu'on ait quelques instants d'inventeurs
souhaité on va en parler d'abord vous
avez aussi annoncé à l'as saint-etienne
en tout cas c'est l'entourage de martine
aubry qui a annoncé hier matin la tenue
d'une réunion le 26 novembre
alors il va y avoir alors c'est la
réunion des deux socialistes deux
communistes n'ont pas tous j'imagine
d'écologistes il arrive à martine aubry
de christiane taubira vous-même
notamment ça sert à quoi ce genre de
réunions à rallier encore une fois de
plus les les opposants de françois
hollande n'ont su ça c'est dépassé choix
qu'il faut tourner la page de ce
quinquennat il faut le faire d'ailleurs
sans polémique avec un peu de gravité
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya eu encore une
fois beaucoup de beaucoup de tristesse à
vivre cette période je le dis clairement
nous sommes battus pendant dix ans dans
l'opposition pour une alternance nous la
gagnons grâce aux français qu'il faut
confiance à la gauche on en 2012 et
ensuite on voit la façon dont les
engagements n'ont pas été sérieusement
tenu donc il y aujourd'hui des moments
où on se rassemble
avec ce que j'appelle la grande gauche
la grande gauche c'est celle de 1981
mais aussi de 2012 c'est celle qui
exerce des responsabilités dans de
nombreuses collectivités françaises et
pas seulement à paris
donc cette gauche là qui veut tourner la
page du quinquennat de françois hollande
il est naturel qu'elles qu'elles se
retrouvent pour échanger pour travailler
et pour inventer l'avenir parce que on
va pas rester scotchés au au bilan de
françois hollande au terme d'un
quinquennat extrêmement défensif qui n'a
pas tenu ses promesses qui a été un
moment de réformisme tiède qui a manqué
d'ambition donc savez ce que je reproche
aujourd'hui à françois hollande et
à ceux qui ont suivi jusqu'au bout c'est
pas seulement ce virage libéral sans
préavis
c'est avant tout d'avoir manqué
d'ambition pour la france d'ambition
transformatrices celle que nous avions
imaginé quant au bourget où ensuite dans
les élections législatives
nous nous portions les couleurs de ce
changement est ce que vous même en tant
que porte parole un peu de ce qu'on a
appelé les frondeurs vous n'êtes pas
qu'aux responsables finalement de cela
et de l'opinion qu'on a vis-à-vis de
françois hollande
il a été critiqué par vos amis je pense
notamment à philippe baumel qu'il était
sur nos plateaux dès le mois d'août 2012
et qui déjà disait ce quinquennat vers
un échec
on a l'impression qu'il n'a jamais été
soutenus quand même pas par vous n'avez
jamais vraiment accepté l'issue de la
maison ont commandé bommel et beaucoup
d'autres d'avoir pendant deux ans
2012-2014 d'avoir voter les textes qui
était proposée par le gouvernement nous
exprimions des inquiétudes des
désaccords mais on était en début de
quinquennat le président avait la
légitimité du suffrage universel de
l'élection présidentielle et donc nous
nous exprimions pas ses doutes
forcément de façon très publique mais
dès 2014
nous avons lancé l' alerte nous avons
été les lanceurs d'alert de ce
quinquennat n'a pas l'aimer les médias
parlent de fraudes
moi je parle je parle de lanceurs
dallaire loyaux et nous allons
sérieusement vous ruiner jean lui mais
les français n'ont pas élu françois
hollande pour la politique qu'il a menée
en tout cas beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche il me le dise en permanence pas
seulement dans l'année à mai mais
partout ils nous disent en permanence
nous nous avons fait confiance au
président de la république nous avons
été déçus ça veut pas dire qu'ils
renoncent encore une fois à leurs
convictions
la plupart d'entre eux et je l'espère
sont au fond d'eux-mêmes rester à gauche
mais ils expriment de la colère et donc
c'est à cette colère qu'il faut être
capable de répondre sinon sinon tous les
déçus tous ceux qui sont en colère ils
sont nombreux que vont ils faire dans
les années qui viennent pas seulement en
2017 mais durablement
ils vont se réfugier dans l'abstention
c'est à dire non dans la désertion
de la démocratie ou bien ou bien ils
iront grossir les rangs de celles qui
rêvent de prendre marcher marcher sur
l'elysée et ceux qui seraient c'est vrai
pour la france aussi une véritable
catastrophe politique
donc voilà nous avons une responsabilité
nous nous ne pouvions pas rester planqué
dans la tranchée en attendant que ça
passe et c'est pour ça que très en amont
dans le quinquennat
nous nous sommes levés c'est inédit sous
la vème république c'est vrai moi je ne
regrette pas de l'avoir fait même si ça
a été parfois c'est vrai douloureux vous
savez ce qu'il a dit vous attend dans le
fameux livre un président ne devrais pas
dire ça c'est ce qu'il a dit des
frondeurs il a dit je vois que vous avez
des lectures je pouvais j'ai le bon
repos mais il a dit une agrégation de
gens intelligents dont il entend des
gens intelligents on peut faire une
foule idiote
en fait il considère quand même que vous
avez je vais vous j'ai dit et je vais
vous citer ce que nous a dit le
président de la république la seule fois
nous l'avons rencontrée en groupe
ce que vous appelez les fondeurs il nous
est dit après nous avoir entendus
il y avait là une quinzaine de députés
qui lui ont dit ce qu'ils avaient sur le
coeur
il y avait d'ailleurs des députés
bobigny rouille avec air à bouziane qui
le député de côte-d'or moi-même et
laurent baumel et d'autre il nous a dit
le problème avec vous c'est que vous
êtes sincère voilà et je préfère retenir
cette phrase parce qu'elle définit bien
le rapport que nous avons eues avec lui
pendant ces cinq années nous étions ça
sert nous étions fidèles à nos
engagements et nos engagements
eric sicaud ne sont pas ringard quand
nous disions en en 2012
il faut un partage des richesses il faut
une véritable réforme fiscale
quand nous disions il faut un
redressement productif qu'à porter
arnaud montebourg avant cette purge de
la rentrée 2014
je pense que nous étions à la fois
fidèle à la gauche à nos engagements et
puis porter aussi de ce qui est
nécessaire pour la france
voilà donc encore une fois françois
hollande sera peut-être n'en sais rien
candidat à la primaire de la gauche à
cette primaire citoyenne
eh bien il rendra n'est pas encore oui
parce que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
ce constant ce qui rend difficile sa
candidature son bilan la désaffection
deux pans entiers de sa majorité qui l'a
laissé partir savez le temps que
fonctionne à passer pour le livre dont
vous parlez avec avec deux journalistes
auraient préféré qui le passent un peu
plus avec nous peut-être nous aurions
réussi à le convaincre et pour vous
vraiment on a l'impression que le court
rien n'a été positif alors je pense
évidemment au mariage pour tous à la
réforme du collège tout ça c'est à
balayer n'y a absolument rien à retenir
dans jal mais alors et c'est un camion
dont il ya suffisamment de courtisans
pour tresser des louanges que je ne ne
crois pas utile d'en rajouter mais en
même temps je ne confonds pas un instant
ma droite et à gauche
je n'ai jamais dit ou pensé et que
françois hollande faisait à la même
politique que nicolas sarkozy c'est
parfois ce qui nous distingue d'ailleurs
de jean-luc mélenchon
je vois très bien dans les programmes
ultralibéraux des 17 candidats de la
droite ce que viendrait aggraver et
amplifié par rapport à la situation
actuelle
la victoire de l'un d'entre eux mais et
donc j'ai voté des lois
g j'ai apprécié les forfaits en fonction
en direction de l'éducation nationale
vous savez quand il ya soixante mille
postes de créer ça veut dire que on
freine quand même un peu les
suppressions de postes y compris dans
mon département de la nièvre
donc oui j'ai apprécié cela oui j'ai
apprécié l'action de christiane taubira
oui j'ai regardé avec beaucoup d'intérêt
ce qu'est ce qu'on fait arnaud
montebourg aulnoye un morelli filippetti
quand il était au gouvernement dans les
pages mais jamais là quand jeanne mais
ça n'est pas donc une fois moi je ne je
ne suis pas je suis pas procureur je
suis un citoyen élu élus du peuple à
l'assemblée nationale chargée aussi de
contrôler l'action de l'exécutif au
moins au moins pensé que nous pouvions
le faire mais c'est vrai que dans la
vème république telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
le parlement a été vassaliser la
séparation des pouvoirs n'existe plus il
ya des députés qui sont davantage des
porte-parole des ministres que
véritablement des élus de la
représentation nationale tous ces mots
garde un sens pour moi et nous avons vu
au tout au long ce quinquennat que le
pas
le mans était interdite d'action et
l'article en a froid qui a été utilisé à
deux reprises pour la loi macro et pour
la loi et les conneries paraît relever
justement de ce grand des règles et des
institutions et ça il faut le réparer
à l'occasion d'élections présidentielles
de 2012 alors donc vous n'êtes pas sûr
que françois hollande se déclare il y en
a un qui attend est de plus en plus
c'est manuel valls 1 et ils se posent de
plus en plus sans recours hier samedi
après-midi à evry il a dit qu'il était
prêt à mener le combat pour 2017 et pour
vous c'est blanc bonnet bonnet blanc je
pense que manuel valls que je connais
depuis longtemps il est prêt à mener ce
combat depuis plusieurs décennies
probablement vous savez il est certes il
fait partie de celles et ceux ce n'est
pas réservé un sexe et non à l'autre qui
qui ont pensé très tôt très jeune tout
petit que l'élection présidentielle
était la seule façon qu'il y avait de
servir son pays bien moi je pense que ça
n'est pas la seule façon de servir la
france il y en a d'autres
on ne veut ni croyez pas leur pardon
mais je coûtais manuel valls est
visiblement dans les starting blocks les
fourmis dans les jambes si françois
hollande décide de ne pas être candidat
ou n'est pas en situation de l'être
probablement ou doit-il prendre la
relève mais justement il y à des
primaires et s'il n'y avait pas de
primaire
aujourd'hui ça serait entravée par
d'autres candidats seraient vous l'avez
parfaitement déduit de mes propres
engagements et heureusement qu'il ya la
primaire d'ailleurs parce que si elle
n'était pas là cet outil démocratique et
la primaire qui n'est pas un piège comme
je l'entends parfois mais qui est une
façon de réguler la situation à gauche
dans un moment de grande difficulté
politique
eh bien ça serait le feu d'artifice il y
aurait trois ou peut-être qu'on dise à
les garder dans vos propres rangs alors
sur les primaires au d'hernani noëlle
lienemann gérard filoche benoît hamon
arnaud montebourg en belgique au je
prends le pari que je prends le pari que
quand on sera pas dans l'avant primaire
mais dans le hall dont il est beau avec
la ville nature il y en aura moins un
mois il y en aura moins vous en ai
dessus j'en suis certain parce que
franchement déjà et j'en suis certain
mais c'est une primaire et dans cette
primaire encore une fois que des femmes
et des hommes qui ont été d'une certaine
façon sous l'éteignoir mis sous cloche
pendant deux ans et envie de s'adresser
aux français de leur dire non pas et où
la gauche et leur dire le 22 et le 29
janvier 2017
venez prendre en main le destin de ce
pays à travers une primaire à gauche
voilà et ça et ça je pense que c'est un
signe de vitalité
aujourd'hui le pays est par bien des
aspects démoralisé ya un regard très
critique des citoyens sur la politique
dont il faut se saisir de cette prime 1
c'est le contraire d'une aventure
individuelle mais en même temps il y
aura donc sans doute un candidat issu de
ces primaires il a réussi jean luc
mélenchon puisqu'il n'a pas voulu
participer il y aura le candidat
écologiste il jadot il y aura sans
compter l'extrême gauche il y aura aussi
donc emmanuel macron qui grignotent
aussi sur une partie de la gauche c'est
suicidaire cette attitude vous le dit à
qui a eu ou à moi parce que moi je
plains pose la question je plaide depuis
de longs mois et je le redis encore très
récemment
je plaide pour une grande primaires de
toute la gauche et des écologistes ce
qui ici oppose ceux qui conscients
chaque jour qui passe rend difficile les
choses tous ceux qui s'exonèrent de la
primaire vont avoir une responsabilité
énorme dans le résultat de l'élection
présidentielle
on peut pas dire à la fois que c'est le
retour des années 30 avec marine le pen
ou le la revanche de nicolas sarkozy ou
d'un autre à travers la la victoire
possible de la droite et ne pas en tirer
des conséquences
moi j'en ai tiré des conséquences j'en
ai tiré les conséquences très clair en
disant il faut pas multiplier les
candidatures et il faut le faire dans le
cadre d'une primaire citoyenne je pense
que si chacun de macron à mélenchon
avait partagé cet esprit de
responsabilité
on aurait peut-être un peu moins
d'inquiétudes ça ne garantit pas la
victoire de la gauche à la primaire mais
ça évite un éparpillement insensé de
savez pourquoi jean luc mélenchon devait
pas participer d'ici jamais françois
hollande la gamme je ne veux pas appelé
à voter pour françois hollande vous vous
ferez sans problème mais
je considère que françois hollande ben
si les candidats ce soir c'est banks a
dit l'agent secret quelques obstacles
par ailleurs je pense que la primaire
peut se gagner à gauche réellement avec
une gauche authentique et moderne
et si jean luc mélenchon pense un
instant qu'il peut gagner l'élection
présidentielle
mais qui peut être battu à la primaire
citoyenne c'est pour moi une
contradiction qu'on ne peut pas dépasser
donc je pense que chacun on aurait dû
avoir à coeur c'est de s'arrêter
l'honneur de tous de participer à cette
primaire de défendre des projets et les
quelques millions de citoyens auraient
pu en effet sélectionné le candidat avec
deux tours d'élections ça donne la
possibilité c'est vrai dans un premier
temps de réduire le le champ des
possibles et dans un deuxième temps de
choisir un candidat et je pense que 7,7
cette formule qui n'est pas magique a
néanmoins permis en 2012 à la gauche de
gagner l'élection présidentielle et
pourrait permettre en 2010 est de ne pas
la perdre en tout cas au vu du contexte
ça semble bien mal parti pour l'annoncer
à ça que je suis je pour ça que je suis
très inquiet je veux le souligner si
vous le permettez je pense qu'il ya un
risque d'effacement de la gauche dès le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et l'éparpillement des
candidatures évidemment en plus donc vu
le contexte international il ya quelques
mois le brésil on vient d'avoir le
l'élection de donald trump aux états
unis je parle même pas des pays d'europe
qui tendent vers le populisme est ce que
vraiment les pays occidentaux
l'attendent la populisme justement se
droitise je filtre à droite la raison de
tout ce qu'on observe en grande bretagne
aux états unis au centre de l'europe
aussi c'est souvent la condition des
conditions de vie réelles des gens
pensent et l'appauvrissement c'est la
désindustrialisation
c'est la pression extrêmement fortes de
la mondialisation dans ce qu'elle a de
plus brutale et ce qui n'en professer ce
qui produit oui c'est ce sont ceux qu'on
appelle les perdants de la
mondialisation mais ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que quand on
est ouvrier dans le secteur automobile
dans aux états unis ou en europe
quand toutes les productions depuis 20
ou 30 ans on délocalise
et que l'europe ne remplit pas sa
fonction de projets de protection
d'organisation des marchés de soutien à
ces à des filières stratégiques
on peut comprendre même si on ne partage
pas parce que les conséquences les
remèdes peuvent être plus graves que le
mal on verra aux états unis dans
quelques mois avec donald temple je ne
partage pas évidemment ce choix là mais
je vois très bien quelles en sont les
causes et pour vous vous dites dans
votre livre aussi par rapport à la
france la plus précisément que ce n'est
pas la france qui se droitise mais c'est
là la gauche qui s'efface et qui safadi
oui la gauche la gauche quand elle
s'oublie ne doit pas être surprise de
voir il ya des gens qui sont qui se
prononce vraiment pour des mesures de
gauche je pense à mélenchon je pense à
vous ça prend pas mais parce que que
regardent les français aujourd'hui il
regarde le la chronique du quinquennat
avec avec ses résultats ou son absence
de résultats il regarde la façon dont la
fonction présidentielle et a été utilisé
il regarde la manière dont les fractures
territoriales demeure intacte vous savez
on les français n'ont pas le sentiment
d'être plus libre plus égaux plus
fraternelle quatre ans après or c'était
ça la promesse de 2012 être plus libre
plus égaux et si possible plus
fraternelle alors il faut les îles et
l'archipel donc les îles assez les
différentes composantes de la gauche
vous dites qu'il faut recomposer cet
archipel
il faut sortir du ps selon vous c'est un
internaute qui nous demandent pourquoi
on ne sort pas de ce ps qui a fait
monter françois mitterrand en fait
c'était le but de françois mitterrand
pour accéder à l'elysée les sites de
l'archipel ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la gauche a toujours été
plurial depuis jean jaurès la star et le
restera à l'avenir parce que moi je
pense que là la gauche ne meurt jamais
elle doit changer mais elle ne
disparaîtra pas les parties peuvent
disparaître des partis dont il dit
souhaiter que le plat goody star et je
pense qu'il faut sortir des murs je ne
dis pas qu'il faut partir dans des
aventures
parce qu'ici pour la gauche l'avenir
c'est une sorte de crépuscule avec des
groupuscules voyez on imagine bien ce ce
film là
et donc je ne je ne dis pas qu'il faut
qu'il faut se disperser je dis qu'il
faut de façon très volontariste très
très imaginative changer ces partis ne
sont plus en état simplement d'être
rénovée et donc j'appelle c'est vrai
dans ce livre c'est l'une des raisons je
le fais aussi pour la france parce que
si la gauche française n'existe plus que
restera-t-il l'illusion de l'extrême
droite la droite dure et quelques heures
sachs au gré des élections
présidentielles donc non je pense que il
faut réinventer la gauche france c'est
pas un jeu de mécano c'est quelque chose
de très sérieux et il faut le faire
évidemment avec beaucoup de ceux qui
sont engagés aujourd'hui dans la gauche
politiques syndicales associatives et
culturelles mais aussi avec une nouvelle
génération
il n'y a pas de relève de génération là
pour le coup on pourra s'interroger sur
le coma clinique de la gauche idress 30
secondes vous avez tadié qui vous allez
soutenir pour cette primaire parce qu'on
vous a vu au mont beuvray avec arnaud
montebourg
tout ça ce n'est pas bon mais vous
n'étiez vous n'étiez pas à franges et
alors est ce que vous j'étais alors
rejeté tous les ans est là vous allez
moi même au niveau là à l'amour on y
sera j'espère l'année prochaine je
donnerai mon parrainage à l'un d'entre
eux évidemment et comme j'ai la
responsabilité d'animer un courant
d'idées au sein la gauche et du parti
socialiste j'ai pensé que en ce moment
j'avais nos affaires effectivement que
de rentrer dans cette période là j'avais
animé un courant j'avais à faire en
sorte que la primaire justement ne
connaissent pas de retard à l'allumage
et c'est à cela que je me consacre on va
suivre tout ça merci christian paul
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dimanche en politique se poursuit juste
après le flash régionales aujourd'hui
francis le pays reçoit marine le pen et
la semaine prochaine ici même place au
débat nous évoquerons l'avenir des
centres villes avec les maires de mont
soleil
de nevers et de joie dit bon dimanche à
tous merci